remember
for these mothers The Wait For answers
outside the hospital Mortuary is
unbearable
their children are missing the fear that
they are among close to 40 students
killed in a nighttime raid by suspected
Rebels as they slept
some were burnt beyond recognition
others shot or killed with machetes
after militants attacked their school in
mapondway in a remote corner of Uganda
close to the border with the Democratic
Republic of Congo the military have
reported that six others were taken by
the attackers to carry food stolen from
the stores I was well not yet identified
where is among the the those ones who
were taken or is all is among those who
were a band so we are still waiting for
results
from the government and from the medical
from medical officers
the Allied Democratic forces is being
blamed for the massacre an extremist
Group which has been launching a tax
from volatile Eastern Congo for many
years
there's frustration that the children
weren't better protected
and many people are killed
the security
hears the border is secured what was
this security when these killers came to
Uganda where was the security
[Applause]
one guard and two local residents are
also reported to have been killed in the
deadly raid eight other people are said
to be critically ill in hospital
and now the race is on to rescue the
children taken across the border
Emma virtually Sky News